hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Constantine episode 10 video
we finally got to meet Felix Faust I was
totally surprised whenever I heard they
were gonna bring him on the show I never
thought it was gonna happen to be fair
back at Comic Con the producers said
that they had free rein in the magical
corner of the DC Universe
that's not carte blanche they can't do
anything they want but they can do
almost any magic based plot they want to
do within their budget I know a lot of
you are asking about Constantine season
2 they still haven't said anything yay
or nay so it's still not canceled but it
hasn't been picked up for season 2 yet
now let's talk about Felix Faust in case
you didn't recognize him he was actually
played by Mark Margolis from Breaking
Bad all I could think was like the
little ding ding bell sound just like
him sitting in his Felix Faust costume
just hitting that little Bell from
Breaking Bad okay so moving on to top 5
moments from the episode just careful
for spoilers because we'll be talking
about specific moments so number 5
Chaz's backstory explained so some of
you younger people watching this video
might not recognize it but the bar fire
is actually modeled after a real-life
event there's this 80s band called great
white they were playing a show in Long
Island and there was this fire in the
bar that they were playing in and a
bunch of people ended up dying it's 47
total and and I think the numbers kind
of interesting just because you could
look at it as being just enough lives to
get them through five seasons I mean we
have no idea if they're gonna get five
seasons if we have no idea if they're
gonna get two seasons it's just like you
could see them stretching that out like
he loses just enough lives to get him to
season 5 the book of pictures at the end
of the episode that he was showing his
daughter those are all the souls that
are inside of him if anyone was really
confused about what was going on with
that spell it was a spell of protection
just remember magic always comes at a
cost it's like a monkey's paw situation
where like you make wishes but the
things that you get end up being really
twisted versions of the stuff that you
wish for number 4
Zedd confirms resurrection Crusade I was
happy to see that they finally confirmed
it I mean it was pretty clear they were
going in that direction we've only got a
couple episodes left so we've got to
find out who her father is we got to
meet that person I've said it in a
couple of my previous videos but the
plan that her father has for her is
she's going to be like the new virgin
mary' like she's going to give birth to
the new Christ or that's what he thinks
I'm kind of waiting to see how they
dovetail that with the rising darkness
storyline just because in the comics
they're kind
unrelated but because this is TV they
try to make everything fit together just
a little bit by the end of the season
like all the storylines tend to converge
in the finale number three meet Felix
Faust so a quick version of Felix Faust
about seven thousand years ago he was
serving a king in Africa it was a
fictional place called core the king of
that nation was a wizard himself Faust
challenged him for dominance lost and
banished Faust to another dimension so
he was separated from his body then in
the mid 1920s a character named Deacon
Dratch who was an aspiring magician
himself accidentally summoned Faust in
Faust took over his body he was mostly a
Justice League villain early on he was
actually one of their first big villains
in the 60s his first issue was Justice
League number 10 in 1962 so he mostly
gets caught up in dr. fate Black Adam
Shazam Justice League story Alliance
characters from those comics I know
everyone's wondering if Constantine is
ever going to crossover with arrow there
is a point in the new 52 universe where
Felix Faust character ends up crossing
over with the Justice League dark
characters in Nanda Parbat
obviously the territory of ratio ghoul
so you could consider that loose ties to
arrow but I mean there's no way they're
gonna do that this season there has been
no evidence of magic on the flash or
arrow yet I am really interested to see
if either of those shows is ever gonna
try it though number 2 Constantine
versus the demon if you were confused by
why Faust was pissed with the way
Constantine took the demon down which I
thought that effects on the demon were
actually pretty good like the way they
did it I think somehow Faust lost the
power of the souls that the demon had
taken and if he had been managed to hell
the way Foust's had asked he would have
been somehow been able to get those back
it's totally possible he was just being
a dick though changing the terms of
their contract Faust is a total dick
character I always like it whenever
they're chasing something down or trying
to defeat something with magical
artifacts I'm surprised they haven't
done it more often I think a lot of it
has to do with the effects budget like
until they add CG effects it's just them
walking around with a prop in their
hands like you can put the helmet of
fate on but unless you add special
effects it just it just doesn't come
across as very grand and my number one
moment
Chas versus Faust this is a Chas episode
so naturally they give the badass moment
to chas he was just like writing over
everyone roughshod in this episode I
actually
liked it we haven't seen a whole lot of
him and when we do see him he's usually
riding shotgun to the other characters
so Chas on the warpath is a lot of fun
in the fact that he's doing the grand
hog State thing where he just throws
himself on grenades to solve problems
just in terms of their dynamic he's
meant to be the Diggle of the group like
the voice of reason so I would like to
see him call Constantine on his [ __ ]
more in future seasons if we do get a
season 2 ok so here's my big question
for you guys when do you want to see
Faust come back on the show I mean do
you think it'll happen before the end of
this season personally I think it would
be a season 2 it the based on the way
they left the character I feel like he's
floating around in the nether regions of
some alternate dimension I didn't really
have any significant thumbs down other
than the wife Chaz's wife she just
didn't feel like she fit into the world
of Constantine it's always frustrating
when you see the odd character out where
it's like the one character who isn't in
on the secret then at the end of the
episode she went from being super pissed
at Constantine to totally drinking the
kool-aid Oh Chaz we'll be back in a
couple hours after he's reassembled so
if they if they did not visit his wife
again I would not be upset it's like
diggle's baby on arrow you know it's
really cute really fun to see it once
it's like ok this exists but you don't
have to see it every week otherwise mark
Margolis
totally awesome is Felix Faust totally
gonna see him again remember separating
the soul from the body very important
thing so his soul is just floating
around in the ether right now so really
big news about next week is we're
actually going back to Ivy University
we're gonna see Richie Simpson again
which I didn't think that we would the
producers have said that it's gonna be
like his art from the Hellblazer comics
I'll talk more about that whenever I
post that video I think I talked a
little bit about it in my episode 1
video whenever I was doing a breakdown
for Richie's character he has like one
really huge comic book art just in in
related news I didn't get this in my
arrow Q&A so just in related DC news
there was a description that dropped for
episode thirteen canaries it's very very
spoilery but it goes into the direction
that the back half of the seasons gonna
go
what's going on with Oliver's character
so if you want you can read that online
and then in unrelated x-men news they
cast the young versions of Jean Grey
Cyclops and storm of all the actors the
most notable one is sophie turner she's
gonna be Jean Grey fingers crossed for
Sansa Phoenix storyline the movies x-men
apocalypse so it's going to focus on a
pock
but that doesn't mean that we might not
see the Phoenix people are a little
confused because there are older
versions those characters that the cast
they're not gonna be including any of
those people it's only the younger
versions we're gonna see those so
they'll be like early 20-something
versions of those characters I'm not
planning on doing a separate video for
that so if you guys have any big
questions about x-men stuff you can you
can also put them in the comments for
this video
once again huge thank you to all you
guys that are submitting subtitles on
all my videos you guys are amazing
everything in terms of like comic book
TV pretty much back next week so while
you wait for everything you can click
here for last week's Constantine video
if you need to catch up and you can
click here for my arrow Q&A my arrow
flash Q&A thank you so much watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
this weekend
you